great season everyone that Ali had me
good yeah will propose yes there he is
man oh great job Jana and goober that
Aunt Viv finger-point you did you not go
oh thank you hey could we talk to you in
my office yeah I don't think my not
Janet please have a seat can we get you
anything coffee tea Kleenex because
you're about to be fired
excuse me fired what do you mean fire
she calmed down okay mary-kate and
Ashley are sleeping next door
this is ridiculous what do you mean oh
[ __ ] production has cue cards for a
reason you can't just be going off-book
you didn't complain when I went off-book
last night okay Janet I wouldn't worry
even a little bit there is tons of
acting work out there for middle-aged
african-american women it's the nineties
oh really like what name one show Family
Matters that's a show name another shell
step nice town they are all way Oh
Kody's like Philippine ativ American
he's probably the whitest person that's
on the show oh my god oh my god there is
a huge diversity problem in television
anyway you're still fired this is out of
control
okay this show needs me what are you
gonna do huh kill me off
okay make I'll fulfill a single Uncle
America won't want to see that oh this
is so embarrassing for you you think
we're gonna kill Aunt Viv okay so what
are you gonna do what am i replaced
hi gentlemen here's your coffee oh
thanks you knew ONVIF are you joking me
right now
oh no we're not the jokesters but i knew
on babe sure is that wasn't an
earthquake Uncle Phil was jumping rope
that is comedy are you being serious
right now we don't even look alike I
think you do yeah me too look at you
squint your eyes and do this
which ones which which one who are we
firing okay you know what stop it
I am a pinnacle in this show and I can't
be replaced by some wannabe I said I
want to be what's wrong with her oh
she's a robot now Jana if you just want
to grab your face robot yeah well
they're easy to work with and they don't
go off-book
it's the new wave Janet Holly Robson
Pete from hangman mr. Cooper
robot Lisa from Saved by the Bell a
robot Dustin Diamond was a person
replaced him with a robot first white
robot hey there he is you know what I am
NOT going okay I'm not going anywhere
Malcolm X says a woman who stands our
ground is a woman that's all are you
kidding me no cause you know what you
won't even know Will Smith's name in
five years what are you gonna do huh put
him in a movie about an alien invasion
where he saves the world on any given
holiday going me that idea I got all hey
Carol did you hear that
write that down I knew what viv do you
know who Malcolm X is no I do not
oh she's perfect want to go to Eddie
Bauer and get some new slacks you know I
do
you